[Musique]
retrouvez allons nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons nous l'émission sera découvre la
réunion ensemble vous allez paraît alors
à l'eau
[Musique]
j'avais bien pas moi
lardin alors au cinq mille et mille et
dans la commune de saint benoît plus
précisément sur le parking du sentier
des annales et nous nous ça des couples
sentir en faisant une boucle et la
mivoie que nana du monde là en train de
travail en direct sur abonnement bonjour
bonjour bonjour monsieur bonjour bonjour
tout avoir oui il sera bien temps avec
que sans en être une fille un petit peu
là seulement on pourra prendre mal à
dresser un pv panier en bois goyavier
d'accord et bien causerait là
aujourd'hui pour un entretien le site
met propre le passé balié une taille les
iem pato l'ipres boisbouvier et que ça
ne l'est le puissiez pourrait-il bien
ici le matin tous les oiseaux de la leur
comme encore déjà eu mon
travail d'accord mais en tout cas les
chouette alors - vidéo a dévoilé ravenal
mais chez tonkam outil souple et le
sentier des lois à la hausse et passe
pas alors d'accord juste par la wii si
ça monte au hockey balle et baume &
mercier des deux corps c'est à trouver
allez allez bye
[Musique]
rien que ça mais moi
si l'on retrouve mon moment
rien que là même où regarder
[Musique]
le nom
e
nikon est à la base mo nous reste à
alors du coup nous arrive un croisement
parce que faut savoir que 20 de santé
dana plusieurs boucles dans la boucle si
vous passez par là par exemple nova
aurait vais à la route et nous nous va
aller par là et bâtons bien mais on y
arrive bonjour bonjour wade est la cause
du coup comment ça c'est parce que
paysage joli coup elle s'inspire un peu
d'accord et l'année de nous sentir
annales et où vient souvent ici où
habitait la même oui mais habité sainte
anne b
comme bouclé un court-courrier impubère
le parcours est bon je dis d'accord et
émettre un portrait nu du coup un peu
les pieds dans l'eau si l'accord est en
train de pointe quoi c'est bien c'est
vraiment plus plaisir avant tout le
plaisir
est vrai du coup alors le haut niveau
difficulté est ce que ça sente il est
difficile voilà plutôt bien c'est
d'aller coacher tout akon a la cote
vulliet s'est fait vraiment des bons et
6 novembre sinon accessible à tout le
monde les dix semaines à des
aménagements dans le sentier est ce coup
là où la route est assez bon aménagement
l'aspect intéressant oui ben vraiment
apple a fait les échelles à des échelles
de l'escalier d'accord bad bonn bon
d'accord le bal a bien été aménagés les
choix d'alors
la même alors du coup ça passe subtile
passerelle et en plus me wanna die
monsieur l'entraînent contôler chinois
pour faire la danse bonjour bonjour
oui eh bien oui oui gateway concentrer
un peu la larme en train de contrôler un
peu la passerelle parce que latine quand
même pas mal de visseries et
boulonneries là parce qu'elle a été
posée récemment et
il faut voir si a pas desserré la pascal
d'important parce qu'on a découlé de
colas plus tôt mme larivière descendre
un peu dangereux les travaux a été fait
par le département est financé à 75% par
l'europe faire dire les 25 c département
est-ce que tu l'as fait aussi d'autres
travaux si ceux-ci de l'a9 pause les des
passerelles des échelles des engagements
les terreaux fait des listes garde-corps
les endroits et risque de chute ces cinq
sentiers familiale donc la marmaille
dedans il faut le cimentier les quand
même agréable pour la signalétique a été
posée dernièrement aussi par vnf coquet
est ce qu'on a vraiment un point de vue
alors ce sont aussi eux ne va plus au
point de vue et n'a un point de vue il
est bien déterminé d'accord c'est la
fédé n'opposer des délices
défilent pour une protection et comme un
jeune garde corps ah oui à bas les gars
y'a vraiment alors votez bédié
dans la merde est magnifique et sénégal
juste et à la nana la ville de saint
benoît alors du coup de l'ue se sentir
arnal et tombe bien justicier nous un
joli alors annales nous dit aussi
ravenala ou sinon lab du voyageur
pourquoi pas les lacs du voyageur parce
que quand la pluie tombe alors il va
récupérer de l'eau dans seconde branche
ligairi qui peut jusqu'à un litre 5
d'eau de pluie et paraît qu'à l'époque
comme une voyageant la veste oif et bars
à thème est fait un trou juste au niveau
du tronc vous a pas besoin de boire à 12
en tout cas le sentir annales les
vraiment guerre
[Musique]
abate béton bien dans une famille pense
à l'ancien petite pause bojan messieurs
mesdames vous jeu comment lé savoir
qu'ils essayent reprend un peu
respiration à d'autres même les oiseaux
laurent bezeau l'infamie la nama il a
dit 500e aram ier ce que les vrais à
wayne confirme oui mais voilà fatigué
que les marmailles mhr mariam avaricieux
d'accord mais pas à toi tu as rêvé à ça
est-ce que vous êtes l'un pour autant
car
c'est important c'est en tout cas le
temps comme ça l'a bien vite à nous y
sommes et ça nous apprendra en maille
voilà il met à l'ida la nature recherche
un tout petit jeune parce que nous
faisons n'est tout faits un peu dans les
villes dans les machins donc
c'est vrai il a de quoi voir
effectivement l'école c'est bientôt
l'heure et du coup toi est ce que tu
aimes bien marché est ce que tu avais
bien aimé ce parc hôtelier clé avec la
famille la lidho rien faire à la maison
que mamie
plus tôt la réunion où les larmes mon
pays comment il
la réunion ça même album
ap le respect pour mon pays vraiment
après des bises on lit
et ben voila nous quitte le sous-bois du
sentier des ravenal et si nous gardent
bien ici rotos le parking 700 m en tout
cas elle était vraiment gala toute
balade et bien maintenant rotois parking
pas à l'arrêt mais nous ça va
[Musique]
p'tet ben voilà nous arrive au sein de
la commencer sur le parking en tout cas
la rhino nana ghayaza fait poids allons
pour le temps vise italie et puis ça
rendez-vous un prochain épisode de
l'émission allons nous cette fois il ne
sera dans la commune de saint-andré et
nous ça découvre le sentier dioré
gaillard semaine approuvent
vous menez la même
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présentée par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]